[Music]
john joins us up next in the los angeles
area john welcome to the show
hello how are you guys
good how are you
i'm doing all right
what's going on
all right uh so uh i'm a recently
graduated senior and our class uh just
finished the uh
the foundations and uh uh personal uh
finances oh awesome awesome congrats
thank your teacher for teaching our
personal friends thank you guys
yeah i just want to thank you guys so
much uh because we learned a lot and uh
i really appreciate it that's our
pleasure
so what's going on with you how can we
help
all right so uh today's our last day of
uh class and we just wanted to call in
uh with the questions um i am uh
you know i'm getting ready for college
and i have a bit of money saved up i
think i have about a semester's worth
and um i was just wondering uh how would
investing while in college work you know
if i should do any investing at all
um good question so you said you have a
semester's worth how what's the rest of
your plan to get through college
debt-free because that's your goal right
now
to invest in yourself yeah
um
i'm sorry i just i didn't quite
understand you could you counseling how
do you plan on going through the rest of
college debt-free
um so
during the this summer uh before my
freshman year i'm going to work full
time and hopefully have about the rest
of the year maybe a little more paid off
and then during the summer i will work
part-time
okay so you're going to do it all
through working paying paying your way
through basically
that's awesome john very good so listen
when it comes to investing in college we
actually say like
it's not necessary even though i know
you guys watch the blake and jack um
we show the power of investing early the
compound interest i know that's in the
curriculum which is awesome and it's a
good teaching point to show the power of
compound interest but really the best
investment you can make right now john
isn't yourself and staying in school
and paying your way through and that's
going to give you the best investment at
the end of all of this is graduating
debt-free and then once you graduate
you're 21 i would press and you have no
debt and maybe you even have extra
savings we've even talked to people like
that that are very weird but they do
graduate with an emergency fund yes and
you and you graduate and you have cash
saved or you get your first job and you
save up that emergency fund then press
play on investing then i would start
investing but i would go ahead and get
through your four years of school
um
if you have any extra money saved that
doesn't go to tuition i would put it in
a savings account for next semester i
would just continue uh to build up a
fund of cash
um to use for tuition or other things
and then again when you graduate maybe
you still have some more money in that
account that you're able to use for your
emergency fund or even to throw in and
start investing because
the the amount of time you're gonna
what you're not gonna make up in those
three to four years is worth it of not
it being an investment but it being
towards paying off or continuing to pay
for school does that make sense
yeah that's awesome is your else class
there are you like in class right now
uh yeah that is so that's awesome hey
class is your teacher there can i talk
to them
oh yeah you can talk to them
mr inkleman i think is the proper way l
a way they're just like cool
by first name mr engleman
yes ma'am hey
welcome to the show we just wanted to
say thank you so much for teaching our
curriculum in your class and helping
this next generation get a handle on
money you're amazing
we've had a great year this year we've
invested a little bit as students and
teaching them and how to save and you
know one of our goals is to get them
through college debt free so john that's
amazing thank you guys i love to hear
that so fun and it's your last day of
school huh
yes ma'am we're at lancaster baptist
school in lancaster california and since
we got on the show the students don't
have to take their final
yes
you can hear them shouting in the
background oh that is so funny i just
channeled my inner high schooler i did i
just got so excited for them
now i feel like rachel we're like cool
now
we help high schoolers skip a final you
all are welcome now go to school debt
free i love that well thanks so much for
the call guys it's so cool that is so
fun favorite call of the day right for
sure
awesome for those of you that don't know
we have a personal finance curriculum
called foundation and personal finance
we have an entire team here the ramsey
education team whose entire day spent
getting this curriculum in schools
helping equip teachers to teach this
course and rachel i've been getting so
many messages because it's the end of
the school year from students saying
like thank you so much we love the
curriculum it was inspiring it was
awesome we're planning on going to
school debt-free and it warms my heart
i'm like there's hope for the next
generation oh man and what a gift to be
able to
have this knowledge at such a young age
because the decisions you make between
19 and 22 follow you even though not all
18 year olds realize that they follow
you for your life and when it comes to
your money i'm like man to be able to
avoid so much and just say no and choose
a different path how much quicker
you win with money by just doing that
and now that they have that knowledge
they get to put into practice right yes
and there's this concept i didn't invent
it i don't know but it's it's
pre-deciding
these students are pre-deciding today
the kind of life they're gonna live
they're deciding the kind of person
they're gonna be
and they're deciding i'm not going to be
the kind of person who has shackles when
i leave college because i thought 150
grand was just monopoly money that i was
going to pay off because i'm going to
make 150 grand the year i graduate high
school college that's the mentality a
lot of students have and so what i love
about this curriculum is we go hey the
culture is lying to you but there's hope
there's a better way if you can learn to
say no to avoid the comparisons to go to
a reasonable school you can afford in
cash to buy a used car in cash your life
is going to be so much better off for
the next 50 years yes oh so much easier
and it's that kind of line in the sand
that you have to draw and it's an
extreme line to say i'm gonna not i'm
gonna live without debt yeah to say that
is extreme these days well even the kids
going home to their parents and their
parents like what you learned that
credit scores are stupid what are they
teaching you in school i know i know but
i love it but it's that but but having
that line drawn so early in life because
i kind of like that was my story right
growing up with big dave yeah you know
teaching us
it was never like a th it was never a
thought for me to even do it because in
my head i'm like well no i'm just gonna
work and i have money in my bank account
off the table so yeah and it wasn't this
extreme thing in my head because it was
so normal in our family but deciding it
that to your point so early big
decisions like that it makes other
decisions
easier because when you take that option
off the table
then it causes you to think different it
causes you to say okay how am i going to
choose something else because when it's
this idea of well i just can't go to
school because i have to i have to take
out loans it's the only way i can go to
school that's the most dangerous yeah
three words and when that's your mindset
right and you say then it is an option
at that point and you allow yourself to
go down the road but if that's not even
an option then you say okay i have no
money how do i go to school do i choose
a different school my my school
selection is going to look different
because i'm not taking out debt uh the
amount of hours i'm going to work the
amount of time i'm going to apply for
scholarships and grant like it get you
ha it forces yourself it forces your
mind to make different options when you
draw a hard light in the stands and say
i'm not going to live with debt and
that's what these students
have done and it's it's an amazing thing
and it's hard four years later they
don't have to shake their fists at the
government and say someone forgive these
loans it's so unfair
instead they go oh i don't have to worry
about that i don't have debt it's not
even it's not even a thing i get to live
my life i get to invest i get to live my
life i can retire early i have options
and freedom freedom and that's what well
that's what winning with money is it's
not
this end game just to pile up and hoard
a bunch of money to feel good and to buy
a bunch of stuff even though we're not
mad at stuff but that's not the end
point because what wealth actually gives
you it's not just the dollar amount in
your bank account but it gives you
freedom it gives you options it allows
you to give there's an overflow there's
a surplus in your life
to sure change your family tree but to
help others right so it's this it's this
cycle it's not just for you to sit there
and hoard but it gives you other things
in life
that you wouldn't be able to have
if you were living paycheck to paycheck
and had debt
um and continued in that mindset with no
money when you have that abundance i
this is a hot take i think it makes you
more selfless because you're able to
focus on other things around you people
who need help where where you can give
some money to help others and so yeah
because you're probably able to get out
of debt for that reason alone i love
that because yeah when you are living
paycheck to paycheck and you owe someone
money and you're going to a job you hate
to pay off this debt
you don't have the capacity to look up
and look at others really i mean i'm
sure there's a time and place but most
of your energy is going to taking care
of yourself because you're having to pay
your bills so once you're free from that
and you have margin again it's it's an
amazing and when you do that at 18
that's amazing i'm so excited about this
next generation